you've probably heard that carbon
dioxide is warming the earth but how
does it work is it like the glass of a
greenhouse or like an insulating blanket
well not entirely the answer involves a
bit of quantum mechanics but don't worry
we'll start with a rainbow if you look
closely at sunlight separated through a
prism you'll see dark gaps where bands
of color went missing
where did they go before reaching our
eyes
different gases absorbed those specific
parts of the spectrum for example oxygen
gas snatched up some of the dark red
light and sodium grabbed two bands of
yellow but why do these gases absorb
specific colors of light this is where
we enter the quantum realm every atom
and molecule has a set number of
possible energy levels for its electrons
to shift its electrons from the ground
state to a higher level a molecule needs
to gain a certain amount of energy no
more no less it gets that energy from
light which comes in more energy levels
than you could count light consists of
tiny particles called photons and the
amount of energy in each photon
corresponds to its color red light has
lower energy and longer wavelengths
purple light has higher energy and
shorter wavelengths sunlight offers all
the photons of the rainbow so a gas
molecule can choose the photons that
carry the exact amount of energy needed
to shift the molecule to its next energy
level when this match is made the photon
disappears as the molecule gains its
energy and we get a small gap in our
rainbow if a photon carries too much or
too little energy the molecule has no
choice but to let it fly past this is
why glass is transparent the atoms in
glass do not pair well
with any of the energy levels in visible
light so the photons pass through so
which photons does carbon dioxide prefer
where is the black line in our rainbow
that explains global warming well it's
not there carbon dioxide doesn't absorb
light directly from the Sun it absorbs
light from a totally different celestial
body one that doesn't appear to be
emitting light at all earth if you're
wondering why our planet doesn't seem to
be glowing it's because the earth
doesn't emit visible light it emits
infrared light the light that our eyes
can see including all of the colors of
the rainbow is just a small part of the
larger spectrum of electromagnetic
radiation which includes radio waves
microwaves infrared ultraviolet x-rays
and gamma rays it may seem strange to
think of these things as light but there
is no fundamental difference between
visible light and other electromagnetic
radiation it's the same energy but at a
higher or lower level in fact it's a bit
presumptuous to define the term visible
light by our own limitations after all
infrared light is visible to snakes an
ultraviolet light is visible to birds if
our eyes were adapted to see light of
1900 megahertz then a mobile phone would
be a flashlight and a cell phone tower
would look like a huge lantern earth
emits infrared radiation because every
object with a temperature above absolute
zero will emit light this is called
thermal radiation the hotter and object
gets the higher frequency the light it
emits when you heat a piece of iron it
will emit more and more frequencies of
infrared light and then at a temperature
of around 405
degrees Celsius it's light will reach
the visible spectrum at first it will
look red-hot and with even more heat it
will glow white with all of the
frequencies of visible light this is how
traditional light bulbs were designed to
work and why they're so wasteful
95% of a light they emit is invisible to
our eyes it's wasted as heat Earth's
infrared radiation would escape to space
if there weren't greenhouse gas
molecules in our atmosphere just as
oxygen gas prefers the dark red photons
carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gases match with infrared photons they
provide the right amount of energy to
shift the gas molecules into their
higher energy level shortly after a
carbon dioxide molecule absorbs an
infrared photon it will fall back to its
previous energy level and spit a photon
back out in a random direction some of
that energy then returns to Earth's
surface causing warming the more carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere the more
likely that infrared photons will land
back on earth and change our climate